Speaker 1: in the altered state that some
are describing, might consider using nukes.
The next question is what exactly would he
knew?
He wants Ukraine.
It doesn't really make sense to nuke Ukraine
if you want Ukraine.
But he's not rational.
This is not a rational guy.
And so maybe the point is use it as a rhetorical
deterrent.
Use it as something to say, Look, I could
be crazy.
Don't keep asking.
Don't don't keep fighting back because I'm
nuts and I'm liable to use nukes.
We don't.
We don't know.
We really just don't know.
And we also don't know how the West would
respond if Vladimir Putin actually launched
a nuke.
It's easy to say, well, it would be a suicidal
action by Putin.
Oh yeah.
Maybe that that could be.
But what exactly?
What exactly is the response if Putin launches
a nuke at the same time?
There are people who said, I can't see Putin
launching a full scale invasion of Ukraine,
and we know those people were wrong.
So this is what we know.
An increased level of readiness has been put
forth.
What it actually means.
We just don't yet know.
The next major piece of news coming out of
Russia is the absolute and complete collapse
of Russia's ruble, which is the currency arguably
now worth less than one American cent less
than one, American said.
One of the things that took place over the
weekend is that there have been swift bank
sanctions placed on Russia now.
I don't mean that they were swift in that
they were rapidly place.
They weren't done swiftly.
Swift in all caps is an interbank messaging
system used to transfer money internationally.
Sometimes when we have like an advertiser
that's based in a different country, Swift
codes are used to transfer money back and
forth.
And over the weekend, it was announced that
indeed, there are sanctions being placed on
Russia's access to the swift system.
There was every expectation that indeed the
ruble would collapse, and it has collapsed.
We're putting up the ruble dollar exchange
rate for you.
And it looks like it fell off a cliff.
I mean, it looks like a mountain with a seemingly
vertical ledge.
And the value of the ruble has completely
and totally collapsed.
Now, obviously, the problem is that this affects
innocent Russian people who oppose this invasion
more than it affects the oligarchs and Putin.
The pressure on Putin and oligarchs is going
to start to build.
That already is building, of course, restricting
air travel out of Russia, restricting their
assets in other countries, shutting down swift,
collapsing the value of their currency.
There's no question about it, but it's also
really affecting the Russian people.
We can already see this.
Over the weekend, there were bank runs and
ATM runs all over Russia.
We're showing video to our video audience
here of people lined up in an ATM to pull
money out in the money running out.
So it's an unfortunate part of the point of
sanctions.
Part of the point of sanctions is turn more
people against